in the new issue of people on newsstands
february 18th linda steps out of
seclusion for the first time in five
years vowing to no longer live in shame
inside the model describes what she says
are the effects of a fat freezing
procedure she underwent between 2015 and
2016. i've always like i said let a
healthy lifestyle and worked out but i
had stubborn fat instead of shrinking
her stubborn areas linda says the
sessions eventually led to bulges that
became hard and even painful an outcome
that affects less than one percent of
patients she says the results left her
feeling quote brutally deformed adding i
don't recognize myself physically but i
don't recognize me as a person any
longer either do you see the angle of my
arms
okay i can't put them next to my body
because this bulge is making them veer
off in an angle i don't think designers
will
burst out she won't want to dress me
with that sticking out of my body the
11-time vogue cover star was suing the
company behind the procedure for 50
million dollars claiming she cannot work
due to its effects as for why she's
speaking out now linda says she's
determined to rebuild her confidence
telling the meg i hope i can shed myself
of some of the shame and help other
people who are in the same situation as
me that's my goal